l'échec de la négociation sur
l'assurance sur la réforme d'assurance
chômage était annoncé né de la volonté
du chef de l'état supplantant celle du
gouvernement annoncé devant le congrès
de versailles concrétisée par le dépôt
d'un amendement tardif au moment de
l'examen du projet de loi pour la
liberté de choisir son avenir
professionnel par le sénat la
renégociation anticipée de la convention
d'assurance chômage alors que la
précédente ne datait que de juillet 2018
n'était pas placée sous les meilleurs
auspices déjà un sentiment d'absence de
respect du débat démocratique
il à vis de nous parlementaires mais
également des partenaires sociaux laissé
planer une volonté de recentralisation
de l'assurance chômage par le
gouvernement c'était une provocation que
de demander aux partenaires sociaux dans
votre lettre de cadrage 3 à 4 milliards
d'euros d'économies que vous n'auriez
pas pu assumer politiquement alors que
par vos propres décisions en juillet
vous faites le choix délibéré d'aggraver
le déficit annuel de l'unedic de 500
millions d'euros c'était une provocation
que de leur demander de négocier sur un
bonus malus d'ores et déjà actée par le
président de la république
ma question est donc la suivante en
supprimant les cotisations chômage des
salariés pour les remplacer par de la
csg évoluant d'une logique d'assurance
une logique de solidarité
n'avez-vous pas implicitement prémédité
la déresponsabilisation des syndicats
est tronqué une négociation à laquelle
vous n'avez peut-être vous même jamais
cru mais dont les conséquences s'il
quasiment la fin du paritarisme dans
notre pays la parole est à porte parole
du gouvernement monsieur le ministre
vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs c'est un terreau madame la
sénatrice conformément à l'engagement du
président de la république engagements
qu'il a pris dans le cadre de la
campagne présidentielle gouvernement a
fait le choix de placer de travail au
coeur du projet politique que nous
portons
vous l'avez rappelé nous avons demandé
aux partenaires sociaux d'ouvrir une
négociation sur l'assurance chômage ces
négociations malheureusement n'ont pas
abouti nous le regrettons d'autant plus
que le gouvernement avait donné un délai
supplémentaire pour aboutir délai
supplémentaire donnée
la demande des partenaires sociaux est
question que nous avions posé alors
reste entière et il appartient au
gouvernement de reprendre la main sur le
dossier de l'assurance chômage
nous le faisons en poursuivant deux
objectifs d'abord lutter contre la
précarité et ensuite inciter au retour à
l'emploi
cet enjeu de la transformation est
d'ailleurs double d'abord inciter les
entreprises à proposer des contrats de
travail plus long et privilégier les
embauches en cdi pour des précarisés et
ensuite toujours s'assurer que la
reprise d'emploi est plus intéressante
que le fait de rester au chômage de très
larges consultations ont été engagés par
muriel pénicaud avec les partenaires
sociaux avec les associations de
chômeurs avec les mouvements
d'employeurs les parlementaires les
organisations de salariés y compris les
organisations de salariés non
représentative et à l'issue de ces
consultations des mesures seront
présentées au printemps
elles feront l'objet d'un décret qui
sera mise en oeuvre cet été vous le
voyez madame la sénatrice
il n'y a dans l'action engagée par le
gouvernement nulle volonté de remettre
en question le paritarisme
mais il y a le souhait réel d'assumer
pleinement nos responsabilités lorsqu un
enjeu aussi crucial que l'emploi que la
lutte contre le chômage et contre le
chômage de longue durée est en jeu et
c'est à cela que nous allons nous
atteler
je suis sûr que cela nous pouvons nous
en réjouir collectivement
je vous remercie sauf que l'on puisse
s'en réjouir c'est une certitude mais
monsieur le ministre dans un
gouvernement il ya ce que l'on veut bien
nous laisser voir et il y à ce que l'on
voit et ce que l'on vit ce que l'on voit
ce que l'on vit et ce que l'on veut bien
nous laisser croire c'est matin midi et
soir un gouvernement qui écouterait les
français un gouvernement qui écouterait
les partenaires sociaux un gouvernement
qui écouterait les élus qui écouterait
les parlements mais ce que nous vivons
est bien différent en fixant un tel
cadre aux partenaires sociaux
c'était un manque ablement la chronique
d'une mort annoncée de la nouvelle
négociation de l'assurance chômage et je
le crains la chronique d'une mort
annoncée de 50 ans de paritarisme dans
notre pays